tell you the one place i don't feel
shameful for leaving food on the plate
though and that's whenever i go to
america
and oh yeah just witness the food sizes
there for
everything like oh my i had that in
[ __ ] chicago when i was at a conal
delay
i'm sure i'm sure it's no surprise to
americans that they're food portions
yeah and i'm just like i had that in
chicago when i ordered deep dish pizza
for the first time and like
because we had never ordered it right
most of us never ordered it we were like
oh yeah it's just the same as a regular
people
so it's like what seven of us there yeah
we'll get five deep dish pizzas
it looks awful am i crazy does it look
it does it taste terrible
it tastes good but it tastes great for
the first slice yeah but one slice is
like eating a whole pizza
basically because it's it's literally
just a whole pizza just stacked on top
of one side
i've had like the like kind of deep ones
yeah not like
there where it looks oh no we have the
[ __ ] dude like it's like a deep dish
it's basically a basin for the sauce
right like it's
like it's a pizza lasagna that's what it
is but like at that point it's like the
whole
the best part of the pizza is the
synergy between
the synergy what are you talking about
bro the the way the bread the cheese and
the sauce is like the perfect amount
you get the best bite if there was one
too many of those
[ __ ] pizza theologists right here i'm
telling you man like you
if there's too much sauce yeah you gotta
drink the pizza what's up with that i
like the saucy pizzas though yeah yeah
no no like the extra sauce
pizzas but i will admit that that deep
dish was like
damn like could you put a straw in it
and drink it probably
that's that's true i mean it goes in
layers like i didn't realize why so many
americans called pizzas pies
yeah until until i had a deep dish pizza
and i was like oh
this is this is a [ __ ] part this is a
pizza is that where it came from
yeah i think so i'm not sure but it i
was definitely eating a pie that was
shaped like a
exactly but i remember as well like when
i went to texas for the first time and
went to like i remember what the italian
restaurant was but it was like a big
italian version and like
portion size is an american no
portion sizes in america are already big
right yeah but in texas it's like hold
my beer
yeah levels of [ __ ] food right so we
went to this italian restaurant and it
was uh it was misty's birthday
so we went to an italian restaurant and
we were like getting all this food
and you know normally when you go to an
italian restaurant anywhere right it's
like
you order like one bowl of pasta each
right like whatever you want maybe share
it around or whatever no
in in this italian restaurant it's like
one dish
of pasta is like can feed like an
ethiopian family for like a year
like it is an insane it's like too much
pasta
yeah and we thought that was already
ridiculous like we couldn't even finish
that [ __ ] but then
we wanted to order a cake right and we
saw oh they sell tiramisu here
and misty's like yeah i want a tiramisu
and normally when you order cake
at a restaurant it's like one slice
right yeah no they brought out the whole
[ __ ] cake it was like it was like it
was legitimately like
this big this bigger like this dean how
much was it
that's like 20 bucks what the [ __ ] it
was like i was just like
i think we ordered wrong and they were
like no there's only one tiramisu on the
menu
so it must mean this wondering okay
that's like just like the only option of
anything is a crate of it yeah
yeah i just want a bit of it and i'm
just like um
and i thought like you know oh maybe
it's like a little bit late maybe it's
like a really fancy tiramisu right
because of the price but no i
wasn't expecting like [ __ ]
grandmother like bust into the [ __ ]
restaurant just be like here you go
sometimes when i'm with americans in
america and they're like yeah that place
is way too expensive you get ripped off
and i'm like bro i got like
like enough to feed my whole family in
my head i'm like no you didn't get
ripped
you've been there you've been to france
bro you get like one string of pasta and
sauce and they charge you twenty dollars
for that [ __ ] would you like
six snails for 20 euros yeah yeah like
i'm like in europe like it's you don't
get that for that much
it's rare like i mean to me yeah la was
super expensive but i always got a [ __ ]
ton of food so i was like
yeah yeah exactly it's just i remember
having to learn the hard way that you
just never order appetizers when you go
to
an american restaurant because there's
been a meal yeah yeah because that's
why do you call it appetizers when it's
like as big as the main course i don't
get it
like in every every other part of the
world you want to happen you have like a
three-course meal sometimes you know if
you're feeling frisky in america you
order one thing off the menu
and that's the one thing can feed a
[ __ ] family for a week one thing i
could
never [ __ ] believe was the concept of
bottomless fries
at a fast food restaurant bottomless
everything bottomless everything like
already like free refills was like a
whoa concept because in australia
there's no [ __ ] there's so many
people right yeah but
i was like oh it's free refills and
bottomless fries i'm like
what is this what is bottomless i just
realized episode is like british and
australian people discover america
yeah what is what's up with all of this
stuff because i was so used to ordering
like a large drink at like a cinema
right like in australia because
you know you could actually finish it a
large drink
in a [ __ ] american cinemas like they
might they might as well have just given
you like
four liters of coke right you just like
blew my mind i had another thing i found
out in the cinemas in america
you can refill your popcorn in some of
that yeah yeah yeah i'm like what
no why is this allowed like i was like
why did i buy the large then if i could
just refill it yeah okay here's the
concept i never understood right like
you can order you go to any restaurant
right usually it's free refills right
yeah this is the drink machine yeah yeah
but there's small medium and large sized
cups yeah why would you not just get
this
why would you not just get a small cup
and then i asked aki and she's like oh
some people are just too lazy to get up
to get a refill
what and i'm just like are you it's like
it's like 20 cents extra dude like are
you really that lazy
like you just be like yeah i'll pay a
little bit extra so i can sit
for longer all americans are watching
this they're like is this
do you agree with the points that we're
making are you frustrated that's what
i've heard from another american
and i've heard from multiple americans i
i don't get butted popcorn
i don't think it tastes good i don't i
just don't eat while i
go to the cinemas don't i it's like it's
like i have to eat i maybe get like a
like a packet of candy or something or
whatever but like i never get popcorn i
need popcorn when i go to the cinema all
right
i don't want to go i'm i'm i'm the guy
who never actively goes out and buys
popcorn
but when someone like offers it i'm like
okay let me just chow down
in my head it's like it's not the cinema
experience unless i get popcorn
and they've that's probably because
they've conditioned me to think that way
right
but i mean i like i mean do you watch a
movie at home and you have to have
popcorn
no no no so why do you have to have a
while because i'm going there
it's an experience i need to have the
popcorn maybe i don't know i think i've
just been conditioned from australia
because popcorn and australian cinnamons
were
stupidly expensive i was in the uk yeah
right
and it's like and as like a high school
student it's like you kind of yeah high
school i couldn't and i think cause
maybe my parents never ever wanted to
buy it
yeah right because like he's like you'd
almost be paying a [ __ ] mortgage to
get like this popcorn and drink
something like 10 pounds in the uk which
is like nearly like what like 14
yeah or something like that which is way
more than in america right yeah like a
large popcorn in australian cinemas
usually cost more than the actual ticket
to go watch the movie
yeah i didn't know yeah i'm just like
why i'll just go down to the [ __ ]
supermarket
like blow and just sneak [ __ ] in and
someone said you know it just doesn't
taste as good
i don't know man when you bring your own
[ __ ] in it just tastes kind of like flat
you know i'm sorry we peasants won't
understand
your passion peasants wouldn't get it as
a
wealthy 1800s victorian lord of the land
i must say but no like in in america did
did you ever go to an american cinema
yeah i did where where they would have
like
so i went to a cinema in wisconsin and
they would just have these
butter machines where you could just
basically press it
so confused like pour just like as much
butter as you can on the pot we had that
we
in vegas we had one that had butter but
also lard
and i'm just like it yeah a lot like
just pure fat yeah mainly this is a
thing yeah
i see i saw it it was in vegas and like
another stain
you just want to put lard on it because
it makes it like extra greasy americans
this is true
what is this yes it is is this true
no no no in i saw it in another state
too like i i don't think it's common
because i only saw it like
very very rarely yeah but it was like
some kind of like lardy like fatty
substance that was sitting next to the
butter i'm like
is butter not fat enough for you that
you need extra fat
and extra grease on your popcorn i just
i remember like i picked it up and i was
like
ugh my hands are oily yeah my hands
shouldn't be oily
it was like touching the back of like an
oven right it was just gross
it was like like the deep fried oil [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ]
i ruined my whole popcorn i put that
[ __ ] on because everyone was doing it
yeah i was like it must taste good and
it's [ __ ] horrible as well like you
can't
put that [ __ ] on your lap because then
the grease stuff like seeps through the
bottom of the bottle
okay like wow like this well while we're
rounding about american things
okay american cheese sauce we're gonna
lose all our
what okay what is american spring
what is american spray cheese i i i'm
just there's there's something that i
don't understand about america
and then there's the spray cheese that
americans apparently love i
i always thought the spray cheese [ __ ]
was just like [ __ ] you'd see in the
movies
and then i went to a walmart for the
first time and i saw it i'm like it
can't be
they're always like they're always like
no it tastes amazing on cheez-its that's
what they always say
yeah it should never be in a can yeah or
when they i remember i was sort of
outside of staying at someone's house in
america and they were like do you want a
grilled cheese
i was like i love a grilled cheese yeah
and then they gave it to me and i'm like
you put the plastic [ __ ] on yeah like
you put the cheese singles
yeah that's cheese i'm like that's not
cheese look on the back it's four
percent cheese maximum i guarantee it
that's not cheese yeah like just because
it says cheese flavoring it doesn't mean
it's cheese
i went to the supermarket and there's
like a kilogram of cheddar for like two
dollars
yeah you you have proper cheese
why not use it they're like put it on
your nachos because they're like they
were like it's too
it's i'm too lazy to cut it though i
think they told me yeah
it's get a knife what do you mean it's
too late
buy utensils i literally would like cut
that [ __ ] like
and grab the block out of the peel the
wrapper and just cut it like that yeah
yeah
i wouldn't even like a normal human
being like why are you making this
difficult
i'm gonna explain because i